hola hola estamos ahora en el problema
número 18 y estoy estrenando colores a
ver qué te parecen estos el problema
número 18 que dice la media aritmética
de x
es que la media aritmética de x
es camps eso quiere decir que el
promedio de xy de james es camps o dicho
de otra manera
x + james entre 2 es el promedio de
estos dos esto es igual a ca perfecto
dice después cuál de los siguientes
incisos es la media aritmética de x gent
iceta en términos de cama bueno lo que
me preguntan es cuál es la media
aritmética de x jay-z es decir de x
maceta estos 3 divididos a la vez entre
el número de elementos 123 entre 3 y lo
que quiero saber es cuánto es esto si
nosotros hablamos de términos de cama
bueno realmente está muy sencillo porque
de esta ecuación
yo puedo despejar la x ma jin si de aquí
despejó a x + yen entonces voy a
multiplicar todo por 2 y me va a quedar
que x más bien esto es exactamente lo
mismo que dos veces cam x may es igual a
2 cam y que crees aquí tengo x magem y
aquí tengo x mayer porque no sustituyó
lo que vale que es más en términos de
que justo aquí y que me va a quedar me
va a quedar que dos veces acá
z entre 3 esto es la media aritmética y
además ya está representada en términos
de campo aquí está involucrada la cama y
por cierto este es el inciso
a ese inciso perfecto ya lo tengo aquí
así que bueno este que estoy muy fácil y
voy a ver si aquí me caben problemas
número 19 no no me cabe porque además
tiene una figura muy muy interesante así
que déjenme borrar expresaron para que
así puedas ver el problema número 19 el
problema número 19 y nos acercamos al
final aun tiene una figura parecida a
ésta déjame intentar hacer aquí esta
figura tengo primero un círculo un
círculo por aquí a más o menos como éste
y después adentro del círculo bueno
realmente no está dentro del círculo
pero tengo un triángulo muy parecido a
este empieza aquí baja con un por acá
algo así y después de aquí pasa con un
por acá
este punto más o menos por acá y después
vuelve a subir
tengo un triángulo que está medio
adentro del círculo y bueno además tengo
esta distancia de aquí esto de aquí es
una altura del triángulo espero supongo
y qué cosas me dan bueno lo que me dicen
es que este es el punto x este es el
punto y este es el punto z y este es el
punto w
este es el punto w aquí está el centro
del círculo y lo llaman om y me dan los
datos de este triángulo me dicen que es
un triángulo equilátero y su lado mide 2
este lado mide 2 este lado mide 2 y este
lado todo este también mide 2 así que
para no confundirnos déjenme quitarla w
y le voy a poner aquí este va a ser w
este de aquí este punto es w
y todo este lado mide 2 perfecto tengo
un triángulo equilátero el triángulo x y
z y además tengo este círculo cuyo
centro está en gnome y tengo un diámetro
porque esta línea pasa por el centro y
por lo tanto este diámetro del centro
jet w nos va a servir para este problema
porque yo lo que quiero saber realmente
es cuánto vale el área de este círculo
lo que quiero es el área de este círculo
es lo que me preguntan
y como podemos encontrar el área de este
círculo bueno lo que quiero que veas es
que si este triángulo equilátero pues
todos sus ángulos miden 60 grados este
ángulo mide 60 grados este de aquí mide
60 grados
este mide 60 grados por lo tanto este
pequeño mide 30 y este pequeño mide 30
perfecto
bueno otra cosa que quiero que veas es
que si yo tengo una altura de este
triángulo va a caer justo en el punto
medio y además este ángulo es de 90
grados este ángulo es de 90 grados y por
lo tanto este ángulo también es de 90
grados muy bien ya que tengo que este
ángulo mide 30 y este 60 y estos 90
grados qué creés aquí tengo un triángulo
rectángulo este triángulo de aquí es un
triángulo rectángulo déjame ver si lo
puedo remarcar un poco este triángulo de
aquí este es un triángulo rectángulo
ahora me voy a fijar en el este
este es un triángulo rectángulo y eso
tenemos lado rectángulo que tiene
algunas propiedades importantes la
primera es que este lado la hipotenusa
vale 2 y por otra parte este lado
sabemos cuánto vale este lado es la
mitad de todo este lado es decir que
este lado vale 1 si todo este lado
mediados entonces esta pequeña parte
vale 1 la mitad de dos buenos y yo tengo
un triángulo rectángulo y me falta este
otro cateto que por cierto es el cateto
importante porque si yo saco este cateto
estoy sacando el diámetro de este
círculo entonces lo que me quiero fijar
es cuánto vale este cateto y para
sacarlo pues voy a utilizar el teorema
de pitágoras el teorema de pitágoras me
dice que a cuadrado más b cuadrada donde
a yves unos catetos esto es igual a c
cuadrada es decir la hipotenusa elevada
al cuadrado
si yo quiero a uno de los catetos pues
vamos a despejar lo de aquí y que me va
a quedar
de cuadrada sería el otro cuarteto
elevado al cuadrado es decir 1 elevado
al cuadrado aquí tengo a cuadrada más y
la hipotenusa elevada al cuadrado pues
es lo mismo que 2 elevado al cuadrado 2
elevado al cuadrado
y de aquí puedo decir que a cuadrada más
1 porque uno al cuadrado es uno esto es
igual a cuatro y ahora si yo paso este
uno restando para acá o resto uno de
ambos lados de esta ecuación me va a
quedar que a cuadrado es igual a tres o
dicho de otra manera me va a quedar que
a es igual a la raíz cuadrada de tres
perfecto
ya tengo cuánto vale el otro cateto pero
si te das cuenta el otro cateto es todo
este diámetro que tengo aquí es una
recta que pasa por un punto de la
circunferencia paso por el centro de la
circunferencia y acaba en otro punto de
la circunferencia todo esto me de raíz
de tres y si yo lo que quiero sacar es
el radio entonces va a ser la mitad del
diámetro el radio es igual a la raíz de
lo que vale el diámetro pero entre dos
dividida entre dos porque es la mitad de
este diámetro y ahora sí ya tengo el
radio y si ya tengo el radio estamos muy
cerca de obtener el área de esta
circunferencia porque como saco el área
de una circunferencia bueno pues el área
es igual a pi por el radio elevado al
cuadrado o dicho de otra manera el área
va a ser igual a pp por el radio pero en
radio vale raíz de tres entre dos así
que sustituyendo me va a quedar piqué
multiplica a la raíz de tres sobre dos
esto elevado al cuadrado
y cuanto es raíz de tres sobre dos al
cuadrado bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
pi que multiplica la raíz de tres
elevado al cuadrado pues es 3
y dos el de pago al cuadrado es cuatro
tres cuartos o dicho de otra manera el
área es igual a tres cuartos de pie
wow este problema esta fascinante me
encantó estuvo increíble un problema un
poco más difícil que todos los demás sin
embargo podemos utilizar bastante del
conocimiento que hemos aprendido me
gustó mucho este problema que por cierto
en mis incisos el área de tres cuartos
de pib es el inciso sem
es decir que este problema tiene como
respuesta el inciso c que dice tres
cuartos de pin estuvo genial me gustó
mucho mucho este problema
pues vamos a hacer el siguiente problema
y que por cierto creo que es el último
problema de esta sección déjame borrar
la pantalla y ahora sí vamos a trabajar
en el último problema el problema número
20 el problema número 20 que dice lo
siguiente
si al número 15 lo dividimos entre el
entero positivo cam el residuo es 3 para
cuantos valores de k esto es cierto es
decir agarramos el número 15 y lo
dividimos entre camps y entonces obtengo
un residuo de 3000 residuo es 3 residuo
es 3 para cuantos valores de camps es
cierto y acá es un entero positivo
como encontramos la solución de este
problema creo que hay una forma fácil
hacerla pero también se me ocurre que
podemos probar con distintos valores de
camps y ver qué residuo dejan es decir
podemos hacer una pequeña tabla por aquí
diciendo acá y su residuo vamos a ver si
me caben por aquí
acá y su residuo qué valores puede tomar
acá acá puede tomar el valor de 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 todos los números menores
que 15 vamos a seguirle por acá 11 12 13
14 y bueno 15 no así que completemos
esta tabla esté por aquí está por acá y
por otra parte me voy a fijar en el
residuo que dejan y aquí voy a poner
residuo pues sí
si yo me tomo 15 entre 1 pues deja de
residuos cero así que éste no funciona
si me tomo 15 entre 2 pues esto es 7 y
sobran 1 por lo tanto tengo de residuo
uno no es 3 por lo tanto no me funciona
a 15 entre 315 entre 3 es exacto 5 por 3
15 así que deja de residuos 0 entre 4 y
4 por 3 es 12 12 y sobran 3 a perfecto
éste tiene de residuo 3 entonces esto si
funciona muy bien entre 5 otra vez es
exacto porque 15 entre 5 estrés exacto y
sobran 0
entre 6 y 15 en 36 es lo mismo que 2
cabe dos veces 6 por 2 12 3 son 15 tengo
de residuo 3 entonces aquí tengo otro
posible entre 7 pues me va a quedar 15
entre 7 es 2 7 por 2 14 para 15 1 tengo
de residuo
entre 8 y 15 entre 8 cabe solamente una
vez y tengo de residuos 7 tengo un
residuo muy grande
entre 9 pues también cabe una vez y
sobran
6 entre 10 cada una vez y sobran 5
aunque lo que éste no está funcionando
después entre 11 pues cabe una vez y
sobran 4 entre 12 cabe una vez y sobra
entre es perfecto aquí tengo otra opción
entre 13 cabe una vez sobran 2 entre 14
que de una vez
sobra uno y entre 15 quedar una vez y es
exacto por lo tanto solamente tengo 123
valores para que pensando en cada como
un número positivo y que me deje un
residuo de tres cada igual a 4 k igual a
6 y acá igual a 12 entonces mi respuesta
es el inciso sem que dice 3 y bueno
aunque no creo que esta sea la única
forma de resolver esto de hecho creo que
sale de una manera mucho más rápida
pensando en el algoritmo de la división
euclidiana en fin llegamos a la
respuesta ya está tenemos aquí la
solución por fin del problema número 20
que es el último problema de esta
sección de la sección número 2 así que
en el siguiente vídeo empezaremos una
nueva sección nos vemos en el siguiente